[Music]
for a show of hands.
How many people in this audience know
who Circle is? What we do? Um, just just
trying to gauge. Okay. Okay. Um, do you
know anything about our developer
tooling?
Gotcha. Gotcha. So, nobody. Okay. So,
this is good. All right.
Um, first, you know, I just want to
introduce myself. Uh, my name is Corey
Cooper. I lead Devril at Circle. Uh,
this talk is about the intersection of
some exploratory work we've been doing
internally
between AI and programmable money. And
um you know one of the things we noticed
a trend in with USDC uh when Circle
launched its digital dollar technology
is that um it was an order of a
magnitude better at doing ex escrow than
traditional payment rails. And so, uh,
combining USDC with AI gives you a way
to do some type of verification of, uh,
workflows that are, uh, happening that
need to be met in order for escrow
agreement to be, uh, honored. And then
you get instant settlement with, uh, a
stable coin that can settle um, faster
than T plus2 around the world.
So, in this presentation, what we'll do
is I'll give you a background on Circle.
I'll give you an overview of our
developer tooling. Then we'll jump into
our smart contract um that powers USDC,
the technology that makes it a
programmable dollar and uh and gives it
features and attributes that you can't
do with uh a digital representation of a
dollar in traditional u payment rails.
And then we'll end off with giving a
live demo of our escrow agent
application that we open sourced
recently. and um allow you all to set up
this in your environment if you want to
locally. I can walk you through doing
that today or we can just do a Q&A. You
can ask some questions about um you know
anything about you know our dev tooling
and and where we see this marriage
between agents and USDC going.
So, just to give you a quick um
background about Circle, um it's a
fintech company um that issues stable
coins. Um we were established in 2013.
Um and some of our our backers are the
pillars in the financial services
industry like Black Rockck and Fidelity.
The reason for that is because we've
we've done uh a really good job of
providing trust and transparency that
the digital tokenized version of the US
dollar or the euro that we deploy on
different blockchain networks is backed
one to one with fiat uh and short-term
treasuries in a bank account. So it's
fully reserved 100%. We also have led
the charge in regulation around this
industry and really helped um regulators
around the world think about this as a
ground breaking technology for payments
and um as you see there's some things
that are happening in the US and across
the world where um laws are being passed
to regulate stable coins which we're
happy about because it's going to give
businesses and individuals opportunity
to take advantage of this technology.
And so,
um, another note is, um, you know, since
inception, we've been able to, uh, be
responsible for settling over 26
trillion of of transactions on, um,
roughly we're on roughly 20 different
blockchains and going right now. But um
that that's a huge accomplishment for uh
the amount of engineering resources, the
product resources, marketing resources
that the company has poured into to you
know allowing businesses and individuals
to be able to take advantage of this
technology and build on top of it as a
payment rail.
So, here is a um a chart or not really a
chart, it's an overview slide, a visual
of the lay of the land of what we offer
as a company.
Like I mentioned earlier, um you know,
we issue USDC and EURC.
Um, we recently acquired a company
called Hashnote where we now have a
tokenized version of a money market
fund. Um, which is going to give us the
ability to do um, something with money
markets that were never possible before.
Uh, to be able to liquidate out of a
money market into USDC 24/7, 365 days a
week. Um and then we have our liquidity
services for uh payment service
providers, financial institutions
uh where we enable them to be able to
mint and redeem USDC um to a very secure
enterprisegrade vault wallet on chain
for uh performing different types of use
cases that relate to payments
um dollar access as well as uh capital
markets.
And on the far right
we have our developer services. And this
portion of um of what we offer is what
will be wrapped into what we will
demonstrate today with the sample app
that I'll demo uh where comprises of
wallets. So well a developer can embed
wallets in their application
programmatically.
We also have uh circle contracts. So
that's a smart contract platform that
enables you to deploy uh contracts
programmatically and read to those
contracts as well as write.
And then uh under that we have our
circle pay master and CCTP. And if
anybody knows anything about
transacting on public blockchain
networks, there is something called gas
fees. And so what we've done is we've
enabled um end users to be able to pay
for gas fees within u USDC. So from the
USDC balance. So it actually feels like
a traditional payment transaction as
opposed to having some native token that
you always have to have in your wallet
to be able to transact. And then since
we're on all these blockchain networks,
there is a lot of fragmentation that we
were trying to unify. And the way we
unify that is with our crosschain
transfer protocol that allows for you to
move USDC between different blockchain
networks permissionlessly. And you as a
developer can build very seamless
multi-chain experiences around this this
protocol um so that you don't have
fragmentation where someone is on one
chain and they can't transact on another
chain. So you can do crosschain
transactions uh and things like that.
And at the bottom layer are uh all the
blockchains that we natively have USDC
issued on. Uh this this list is getting
longer. Um so but you know we are we are
in a multi-chain world where we want
USDC to be the uh premier digital dollar
and so we are building all types of
onchain uh utility around USDC as well
as ERC to make uh this um you know
support for multiple blockchains more
unified. So there will be some other
innovations that we're going to release
in the next couple of weeks and months
um that advance the unification of
balances across multiple blockchain
networks with our um stable coin
technology.
So let's let's dive into USDC um and and
just really talk about the attributes
that are really important to a
developer. And so um one of the things
is you know it is a dollar that is
internet native. And so what that means
is the ledger of that dollar is built
into internet technology which is
blockchain networks and smart contracts.
And so it enhances the programmability,
the transferability
um to enable money to move in seconds
globally. And so it's not constricted to
some of the uh friction points we have
in legacy payment rails.
The other thing is because it's uh
native to the internet, it's it's it has
no borders. Um so it works like email or
or text where you know you can send text
or email around the world. We want to
make money to be that seamless to be
able to transact with. And so um because
of it being issued on public blockchain
networks, it gives it the borderless uh
freedom to be able to transact globally.
And then last, when you have a network
that is permissionless and public and
open, uh it makes it very easy for other
companies, individuals to plug into this
actual network of money, um and transact
with it. And so um it it's scaling very
fast globally because of the openness of
anybody being able to build on top of
this protocol for sending and receiving
and storing uh value.
And so how does this work? you know, uh,
how it works is how USDC gets issued in
the ecosystem is a business gets
approved by Circle to set up a business
account and then they connect their bank
account to our Circle Mint platform and
they wire their fiat to our reserve bank
account. After that that fiat settles as
USD in our bank account, then we mint
the corresponding amount of USDC
and credit their circle mint account.
And so that is how USDC gets issued in
the ecosystem. Now the reverse process
happens when the business wants to get
out of USDC. they can redeem uh and
there's a onetoone with um every USDC
minted to a US dollar. So um when they
want to get out um they get that
onetoone parody and so that is the trust
and transparency that we provide to our
customers. Uh we also um do a little bit
of extra things and you can go on our
website where we have a USDC
transparency page where you can go and
see our monthly addestations. Um and we
have various auditors um that are
independent of the company that continue
to audit and make sure that we are fully
reserved and we you know make sure we
ensure the trust and transparency around
the actual issuance of a digital repres
representation of the dollar on uh
chain.
So now we're going to jump into the USDC
smart contract and really dive into like
what makes this programmable, how does
it work.
So one thing is uh we have um you know
very strict implementation requirements
before we uh deploy USDC on a different
blockchain network. And so, um, here are
the things that we want to make sure
that we can incorporate in the token
contract before deploying it on a
blockchain network just to make sure we
have standardization across the board.
um you know as we um expand to different
blockchain ecosystems, but also too to
make sure that there are safeties uh
provisions that we have built into this
actual smart contract for businesses and
individuals to be able to trust and use
our technology as a protocol for money
movement globally.
And so um here are some of the things I
I'll jump into and and and provide a
little bit more clarity around the
implementation requirements. But um the
first is um allow list and block list.
And so this enables us to basically prot
protect you know um people who use our
token contract from bad actors. And so
if we know someone's on a sanction list
um you know and and they're a malicious
actor, we have the ability to actually
um stop them from transacting and
protect other users from transacting
with that actual user. And so um it's
built in for for safety for businesses.
And then we have um spend on behalf. And
so that's a feature where you know say
if you're a business and you wanted to
create a financial workflow where you
wanted to enable um you know somebody to
spend uh a certain amount of money from
a wallet balance uh and and give them a
cap on that on a daily basis. Um there
is functionality built into it where you
can delegate for uh a user to be able to
spend a certain amount of money from a
actual wallet balance using USDC. Yeah.
Like is a scenario with that like a
corporate um you know corporate account
or something
like corporate business card. So say if
you have u some some virtual debit cards
that you're issuing to your actual uh
employees and the actual debit card is
powered by a USDC balance in a wallet.
You could design basically a workflow
where you could put thresholds on how
much they could spend from that
corporate card. Would you realistically
be able to run that to like thousands,
tens of thousands, hundreds of
thousands, or would that not be a proper
use case?
No, no, you could scale it up.
Yeah. Oops, sorry. You you could you
could definitely scale that that
delegation of spending um for that fat
wallet address with a virtual debit card
uh to tens of thousands. Yeah. Yeah.
Another is is mentor configuration. And
so um you know we we have the ability to
uh add um you know other uh entities to
be able to uh mint from our token
contract. This is something that we
haven't done, but there could be a
future where we could partner with
financial institutions and they have a
balance that they can mint from from the
actual token contract.
And then uh multi-IG transactions. Um
this is this is for you know like if
you're building some type of workflow
where maybe you require the CEO, CFO and
CFO to actually sign off on transactions
that are above a certain threshold. you
can design these type of um
transactional experiences to protect
from um you know a wallet being drained
um based off of like one person having
total control of you know the the
transaction ability of that wallet
coal storage support um a use case for
this is where maybe you know that um
you're running payroll uh on a monthly
basis using USDC for your employees. You
know the date and time that you're going
to be sending money out. You know the
amount. Um you have the ability to to
put those transactions in a ready state
that are offline. And so when that date
and time comes, it's ready. The
transaction object has already been
approved and signed and then you can
just broadcast that to the actual uh
blockchain network to send that off. So
it allows you to kind of prepare
transactions offline.
Is that proof of funds? um uh
transactions so that it's ensure that
the money is there when the time comes.
It it could be designed for that. Uh but
it's more it's more of you have a
cadence of transactions that you know
are going to happen on you know a
bi-weekly or monthly basis and you want
to make sure that that transaction is
already ready to go uh and in a state
where it's already been signed and
approved for and then it can just be
broadcasted at a late later date. So it
doesn't necessarily prevent it from
bouncing.
Uh no no. Yeah.
And then since this is a new concept of
money um and we're constantly, you know,
thinking about ways of how we can
enhance the actual protocol of money
movement, there are times where we need
to pause the contract for upgrading it.
And so this hasn't been done much, but
the most recent one was uh um about two
years ago, a year and a half to two
years ago. And um you know it's USDC
version 2.2. And the main thing that we
did was we um made it more gas
efficient. And so um knowing that we
want to make this technology scalable,
we want to make sure that gas fees never
become an issue. And so we were able to
design different uh functionality in the
token contract to optimize for uh better
gas performance across chains.
And so now I'll jump into the um
contract functions of USDC.
And so these are uh basically the
functions the core functions that a
developer would plug into when um
commonly transacting with USDC. And you
have uh balance of total supply,
allowance, transfer, transfer from, and
approve. And so these are these are um
you know functions that are built into
the actual smart contract that powers
USDC uh that you'll see actually later
on when I do the demo that we'll be
using to actually uh perform the actual
escrow transaction. And so um one of the
the the most commonly used uh functions
from this actual contract list is uh
transfer from. And so uh in that
argument you see you put the uh from
address and the to address and then
amount and you pass that um and then
that gets broadcasted to the actual
block um blockchain network to be able
to actually send that transaction and
you're you're telling it to send
basically money from this account to
that account. and then the amount of
USDC that you want to send. And so that
that's the programmability that you get
with USDC that that is not built into
the digital representation of um fiat uh
in a database. Um and so that's where
the magic allows you as developers in
the room to create these very innovative
experiences that were not available to
us.
And so, um, you know, USDC is, you know,
it's kind of funny, but, uh, it's
designed for agents. Uh, basically how
we've seen agents kind of proliferate
over the last year or so, uh, it seems
like it's just the perfect currency for
an agent to use to transact. And so, um,
some of the reasons why is, you know,
one, you get near instant, uh,
settlement, uh, and built-in
verification of transactions. And so
when an agent is transacting, it's not a
human. Uh and so one thing um you know
you want to do is you want to allow the
agent to be able to to transact and
those agents if they're doing agentto
agent payments, they want near instant
settlement because u these are robots
transacting. Uh, another thing is you
don't want robots to have to deal with
chargebacks. And so that could be a
nightmare because when agents start
transacting with each other, money is
going to flow very fast. And so a
chargeback could be a catastrophic uh
risk to running agent-to-ag payments,
you know, on reversible rails.
The other thing is um you know agents
are are always on you know and so they
need a payment rail that's always on uh
24/7 no banking hours. And so um you
know the the great thing about you know
this public blockchain infrastructure is
you have this compute that's always on
that enables settlement to happen 247
globally with no banking hours. And all
of these transactions are verifiable um
through private and public key um
technology. And so the cryptography um
and and the actual openness of these
actual ecosystems make it a perfect um
payment rail for for agents to transact
because um there's there's no downtime.
Oops. Let's go back. And then the last
thing is I'll go back to the slide where
I was showing the actual contract
functions. It's the programmability. Um,
you know, agents are going to need to be
able to have a lot of programmability
because there are going to be
transactions where they'll need to be
able to um, you know, perform some sort
sort of logic uh, that they need to pass
before they can actually make that
transaction. And so that logic can
actually be built into composable smart
contracts uh that we'll show in this uh
demo of of how like this is great for
escrow because um you know you have the
ability to perform value transfer with
all this conditional conditional logic
that you can actually program in and the
agent can actually interact with that
logic to be able to perform those
transactions. So, uh, very powerful
technology here.
And so, um, now I'll jump into the
sample app. And so, first I'll run
through kind of the architecture, what
we used, and how it works. And then
we'll jump into a demo of it, and then
um, everybody can have time to actually
set it up in their own environment, and
I can walk around and help you out if
you have any issues. So
the core building blocks from a dev
tooling st stand standpoint of what we
used to to build this actual escrow flow
is uh we use circle wallets and so that
enabled us to actually provision wallets
for the agent the u and the two parties
involved in the actual escrow process.
Um and then also too we use circle
contracts. So we were able to um
actually we wrote a solidity contract um
and then we uh deployed that using the
circle contracts API. So um it was a
repeatable um process of us deploying
contracts for each actual um group of
parties that are transacting. And so uh
that API allowed for us to take you know
this this template of a escrow contract
in solidity and repeatedly deploy it and
use it for different parties involved
transacting amongst each other. And then
lastly, USDC um being able to embed the
uh USDC stable coin in the actual smart
contract gave us the ability to um
design basically um a smart contract
that is running off of dollars um and
interoperable with the actual fiat world
as well because uh kind of the likely
process of of some of this will be uh
there's a onramping experience from fiat
to USDC and then there's a off-ramping
experience where the beneficiary wants
to go back to actual fiat and using the
actual smart contract in USDC gives both
parties the trust that they have a
tokenized version of the dollar that
they know they can get in and out of
anytime one to one.
So here's kind of how the onboarding
flow works. As you can see from this uh
this design, you have a client which is
the business and the freelancer and they
both come to a platform and create an
account. And so as they create an
account in the background um there's an
API call to the circle APIs that
provisions a wallet for each of those
actual parties.
And then the next thing is the actual uh
business will take basically a PDF
version of an agreement that they have
with that actual freelancer um that they
probably negotiated outside of the the
platform uh for this use case. uh and
then they would upload that agreement
and what would happen is once they
upload that agreement to the platform it
would pass it to the open a uh open AI's
u API and run it through uh a multimodal
model to actually parse out information
about the actual agreement and so that
information will be related to you know
the the amount um uh that these two
parties have agreed upon as far as the
work is concerned and then the uh the
summary of task has that need to be
delivered in order for the actual um
escrow to be um completed and payout to
happen. And so after that happens,
basically there's a listing on the
platform uh that the uh AI agent
generates and and lists and there's a
human in the loop in this process where
you know the actual business approves
that hey this is the amount I'd agreed
upon. This is the list of um you know
things that need to be done in order to
honor the agreement and receive payout
and uh and this is a good summary of
what the agreement is about. So I want
to publish that listing to the platform
and then after that happens
then the actual business would need to
um create a smart contract. And so since
we've already got a template running in
the background they're not designing
that smart contract themselves. What it
is doing is it's taking the information
u that the agent has parsed out from the
actual contractual agreement and
initializing certain constructor
variables uh for the actual smart
contract to be in a ready state to be
deployed on chain to govern the rules of
the actual agreement. And so those
things are is just simple things right
now. It's just use USDC as the stable
coin of choice for the currency that
flows through. Um also too, um the agent
will will be um given a a wallet uh that
can only be used to actually release
funds from the contract. And then who is
the um you know depositor wallet and who
is the beneficiary wallet. And so those
rules will be will be um enforced within
the smart contract um before it's
deployed on chain. And so after um so so
to deploy it on chain, we're using the
circle APIs for this. And so um after
that that is deployed on chain, there's
a notification that comes on the screen
telling the actual business that the
contract has been deployed successfully.
Um, and in the background, a developer
can use uh the developer console that we
have at Circle to track all this
activity uh and to design web hook
notifications uh as well around this
activity. And so that's one of the
powers of um our dev console. allow for
you to do a lot with onchain data uh
because we're indexing all this
information and putting it in a nice
format to allow you to design different
programmable flows around that
information that's happening on chain.
And so
once the actual contract has been
deployed on chain, the next thing is
you're going to have to the business
will have to actually on-ramp into USDC
or if they have pure USDC, then they can
uh fund that that um actual contract
from um some USDC they already have an
external wallet. And so, um, you will
deposit, you'll call the actual deposit,
uh, function on the smart contract. And
what that would do is that would
basically um initiate an approval for a
certain amount of USDC to be sweeped
from your actual wallet address and
transferred into the smart contract so
that the smart contract can go into a
ready state of letting the beneficiary
know funds have been deposited in the
smart contract. Now it's ready for you
to do the work you need to do to honor
the contract. And so that's that's one,
you know, magical moment where you have
now in this escrow experience a smart
contract that's actually holding the
money in code and there is some sort of
transparency that you know the money
actually is there because you're dealing
with these public networks that have the
ability to verify, you know, that
information by just looking it up on the
block explorer to be able to see that,
okay, funds are actually in this smart
contract. So I know this person's
serious about paying me. So um after
that
then the actual um freelancer
will and for for this actual experience
we we use an image. Um they the the task
at hand was to design basically um uh
some marketing material in the format of
an image um that had certain things
within that image um that promoted the
brand of the actual business. And so
Freelancer uploads that image to the
platform. It passes it off to uh OpenAI
and the agent goes to work and it it
looks and verifies. Okay, does this
image have all the things in it that you
know were required of it in the actual
task agreement? If it does, then it'll
go through a simple scoring system. uh
and and if that system scores it as you
know it's confidence level high that
means okay yes release funds from the
actual smart contract and then the agent
uh can use its wallet to actually call a
release uh funds function within the
smart contract that will ultimately
release funds to the beneficiaries
wallet. And so this is where like the
automation, the verification happens. Uh
where in most escrow situations, there's
a lot of convoluted back-end office work
where manual review is being done and
agents now are getting to the point
where they're they're very good at uh
reading, seeing, hearing, doing a lot of
things. And so what what we think is u
there could be a future where agents
could be a major checkpoint in a lot of
escrow transactions and coupled with
USDC becoming a great way to settle es
escrow transactions instantly when you
combine all this together you can build
some very um cool stuff together. Yeah.
So I did a lot of talking. Let me uh
show the demo because I I know people
want to see that. Um so let me get out
of here and open up my um
app.
Okay.
All right. Let's see.
All right. Can everyone see this? Okay.
Okay. All right. Thanks. Okay. So,
here's the escro agent app. I'm already
logged in. Um,
and I have some transactions that I've
already set up because I wanted to show
you what things look like in each state.
And then I I'll kind of walk through
certain transactions and and get to the
actual cool part of actually um letting
the agent actually release funds. But um
here's a here's a transaction I've
staged and right now it's in the
initiated status. And so this status is
someone has already uploaded a contract
uh in PDF form to the platform. It's
parsed out the information with the
agent u using um the 40 mini model and
then uh that human in the loop process
of approving that hey this this is what
you know the agreement should look like
uh listed on the platform so that the
beneficiary can receive that listing.
And so this is the state of what it
looks like after you get past that. So,
it's showing you um the summary of the
agreement. Uh obviously has the amount
here of $10. And then here are some of
the deliverables. Uh high quality image,
you know, featuring Sparkle Fizzle. Uh
so that's the brand fictitious company
we created. And um and so this is what
it'll look like before a smart contract
is deployed to govern the rules of a
actual agreement.
Now in this state say I clicked deploy
smart contract on chain. It has now
built out the logic and the rules that
will govern this um this agreement. Um
the next thing is you know depositing
funds in the smart contract. So the
actual beneficiary knows that uh you
know this person's serious. The money is
there. It's time for me to go to work
and and do the things so I can receive
the money. Um this is what state will
look like. Uh, and then if you hit this
button, you can deposit funds and it
will withdraw the $10 amount from your
account balance and it'll deposit it in
the actual smart contract and provide a
notification of when that money has
settled in the actual smart contract.
And then once it's, you know, in the
smart contract, the state will move to
locked. And so that means the smart
contract will lock itself. And and now
the the next thing that can happen in
that smart contract is basically the
agent actually reviewing the work and
interacting with it to either release
the funds or um you know revert the
actual funds back to the actual um
depositor. uh if you know a period of
time elapses where you know that person
was never able to kind of meet the
agreement.
So um what I'll do now is let me um run
through a test transaction.
Okay. So let's see
design.
So, here's a PDF document. Going to
upload it.
Let's see.
All right. So, in the background, the
agent was running parsing out the
information in the PDF document. Again,
um it's it's parsed out the amount and
the task. And so, if I hit continue,
what it's going to do is it's going to
generate that listing on the platform.
So, we've got our web hook working. It's
passing updates
uh to make sure
And let me do a refresh so that listing
will show.
Yeah. Okay. Yep. So that's the listing.
Um and so now
what we want to do is um we want to
create a smart contract. So um because
it has all the information that it needs
to actually create this agreement now on
chain. So we hit create smart contract.
What it's doing now is calling the
circle APIs to actually uh deploy that
contract on chain. So
may take a little time but uh
it should work in a few minutes. Let's
see.
Yeah.
Uh actually great question. Uh the
network I'm using is base. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
No, no, no. I mean is is a great
partner. Um but um but we we support you
know all the a lot of different chains.
Yeah. Let me see taking a little time.
I got a follow. Can you do an escro
crosschain or does it have to be single?
Um yeah, you actually can perform
crosschain extra escrow experiences.
Um you can use our crosschain transfer
protocol to do that. So I'll give you
example of how maybe that would look is
it's more of uh maybe a crosschain
deposit. So maybe someone comes to the
platform and the contracts are on base
but their USDC is on Salana
and so they want to deposit from Salana
USDC to base they can send it over the
crosschain transfer protocol CCTP right
and then it will deposit into that base
contract and then if the beneficiary
says hey you know like I'm not on base
I'm on you know another chain Ethereum I
want it on Ethereum then you can do
crosschain, you know, payout from that
contract.
Oh, so it's not actually part of the
contract on the platform.
Right. Right. So, so usually what we've
seen as developers who are building um
crosschain experiences where they're
dealing with smart contracts, escrow, uh
a lot of them pick like one chain where
the actual contracts will live and then
they build interoperability between like
deposit and payout flows. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh let's see
me go here to the
oops wrong one.
[Music]
Let's see something.
Okay.
So, yeah, it's working. It's pending.
It's just taking some time, little
latency here to actually deploy the
contract. Um so these are these are
different contracts I deployed testing
it. So this based upon your
let's see
actually what I'm going to do let me let
me show this cool video so you all can
see like end to end really quickly
because there is you know some sort of
uh latency around the internet in here.
So,
I'll play this video right quick so you
guys can see it in the inflow of like
how it works.
And so another thing too um is you know
you don't have to worry about gas with
these uh with using our tooling because
you can design these experiences and
then we have built-in gas abstraction
with our wallet uh as a service infra um
and so it enables you to really abstract
away kind
dealing with, you know, holding native
tokens for gas. And so we also uh make
it very easy for, you know, as we're
abstracting the gas away, obviously
there's a cost there, but we make it
easy for you to actually uh pay for your
gas fees from fiat um directly from a
debit card that you would or a credit
card that you put on file. Um, but we we
really have uh designed this for, you
know, enterprises um that, you know,
probably aren't web 3 native to be able
to integrate our technology, take
advantage of the near instance
settlement that comes with public
blockchain networks and manage wallets
and transactions at a scalable level to
be able to um, you know,
expand their their actual footprint of
of payments around in the world.
So, um the last thing I have is um
deploying the contracts.
Yeah.
Yeah. you you can actually deploy like a
contract factory uh and then that'll
allow you to kind of create iterations
of that within the contract factory to
be more efficient on the gas. Yeah.
Yeah.
So in the mechanics of what you're doing
is that first step basically taking the
an unstructured document and you
creating basically structured data to
then feed to the circle API in terms of
and I guess how does that piece work? Is
it as as simple as like feeding the
contract to open API and just doing a
little prompting to kind of get the
structured data you want as far as the
JSON format?
Yeah, I'll jump into this right quick
for you. So, okay.
So, yeah, that first um part is, you
know, we've created a prompt to make
sure it outputs it in JSON. So, it
parses things out, outputs it in kind of
a JSON format that looks like this. Uh
and then uh that's how we're able to
kind of feed it through to be able to um
create basically that listing that
adheres to uh a consistent format of of
um showing the actual transaction um
amount and task.
I'm not super familiar with escrow
contracts. Are they fairly standardized
or they come in different forms? And I
guess how uh robust has it been able to
be in terms of handling different uh
formats?
Yeah. So um here's the actual solidity
code. I'll show you uh for the actual
escrow contract here. Uh and it this is
a very simple one. Um it's only like a
couple hundred lines uh and a few
functions. they can get uh very robust.
But if you're um for most for most
escrow um you know experiences
uh this could cover a lot you know for
most escro experiences and there are a
lot of templates out there um since
escrow has been a big thing in the
actual crypto ecosystem um that you can
use. one um is is one that um our
research team worked on. It's called the
refund protocol. Uh I'll pull it up
right now, but it's a it's an escrow
template that kind of gives you all the
robustness you would probably need to
handle um any type of escrow scenario uh
that that has been prevalent in the
ecosystem. Let me pull it up right now.
And um you could actually use that uh
and as a template and and you know add
to it if you want or just use it
straight out of the box.
So let me show you this one.
[Music]
Yeah, here it is. right here.
So if you go to circle research,
uh this is an article about it and it
kind of explains, you know, the
functionality built into it. But also
too, we have a repo. Um it is
where is this repo?
Refund protocol. So yeah, this one right
here. You could use this as a template.
Yeah.
Can you just wait for the microphone so
everybody could hear you? Hold on one
second.
Thank you.
Okay. Um so my my question here is uh
towards the challenges of minimizing
human intervention. Um I I find uh LM
and agents um
sometimes unreliably
non deterministic right
so there is always this pattern of um
the LM or the agent builds like a plan
and someone reviews to approve
um given the nature of um your business
right I I understand that Like
I guess the question here is like what
are for circle AI the biggest challenges
when you talk about minimizing human
interaction using
yeah great great question um so the
question here is you know what what is
um the challenges with minimizing
interactions with payments as it relates
to circle um so I I think that um
our focus as our company is kind of like
creating more of a frictionless exchange
of value using public blockchain
networks for settlement, right? But we
started to see a huge trend uh over a
year ago where um a lot of developers
were building agentic workflows using
USDC as the payment rail of choice to
transact between agents and agents. And
so um what we we think is um obviously
there um the the one thing about you
know um AI is it's not deterministic and
payments are deterministic
uh you want them to be deterministic but
there is a lot of conditional logic that
is happening before payments are being
released in the world and so um what
what I think is right now the best
safest way to design these experiences
is with human in the loop built into it.
Um and and and really kind of focus on
it doing being just a pure review
basically for a person in a actual um
payment operation u job to be able to
have just something else out there that
is doing work 24/7 and saying hey here
are a list of payments that are ready to
go and this is what we've analyzed and
why we believe it's ready to go but at
the end end of the day like you're the
final approver. Uh and so that's what we
think um you know in the near future
combining these technology together uh
it can be a great combination but
autonomously and just you know full
automation of controlling um sending and
receiving payments I'm not sure we're
there right now. Uh but I will say that
um you know the way this AI industry is
moving um there could be a world you
know 5 to 10 years from now where um
people actually trust these agents to
autonomously handle um payments um and
procurement and things like that. So
hopefully that answers your question.
Yeah, but we're we're in the first
inning of this and to be completely
transparent, you know, there's people in
this room who have a lot of experience
building with agents. Um, this is
designed to inspire you all to like test
out the combination of this technology
and and and and give us feedback, too.
Uh, we're learning alongside.
Oh.
Oh. Um, I missed the first part, but
what's the closest real life examples
you have of this
autonomous work evaluation and
settlement? Do you have any kind of real
life examples you can share?
Yeah. Um, so we we haven't released any
anything that's like in production doing
this, but there are companies that are
doing this right now in production. Um
and that is you know you have crossmit
is one company uh and then another
company is um third web with Nebula uh
their model. So those companies are kind
of you know on the bleeding edge of of
offering these experiences to developers
but also kind of you know putting things
out themselves. So I'd encourage you to
check out those two companies. They're
both uh Crossman's headquartered in New
York, I think, and uh Third Webb is
right down the street here in the Bay.
Yeah. Yeah.
Um hi. Um I have a question regarding
like around the escro transactions. So I
wanted to know how feasible uh is it to
implement Jon proof um in this
blockchain based escro transactions.
Yeah. um that that is um that's
something that is is pretty feasible
with the advancements that we've seen
with um proving TLS notary
communications. Um those a little bit
lighter weight to prove and you can
generate a proof faster and pass that to
a smart contract to be able to um
perform uh escrow. Uh so there is a
company called ZKP P2P that actually is
experimenting with this and it's a live
experiment that is working really well.
So um there are different ways you could
you could design these and integrate ZK
proofs into them um that we've seen and
and ZKP is one of them that has done it
pretty well. Yeah, great question.
Yeah, thank you. I have sorry I have
another question as well. So uh could
you go to the slide where the uh
implementation
thing is there for the cold storage
support?
Okay let's see
so here I have a doubt like
um so yes in this like transactions
should not all uh always be
instantaneous. So you should be like
creating ahead of time and broadcast
next month, right? So I'm not sure like
I I haven't done like if is there a
possibility if like uh there might be a
double spending kind of attack if we
like hold uh the transaction and it is
not spontaneous.
Um so the the question is could actually
u generating an offline transaction
that's approved create a double spending
uh exploit is that that that the
question?
Um yes.
Uh um I don't think it could could
necessarily do that. Um, you know, from
from my experience of of people actually
kind of generating transactions offline
to actually broadcast later, I haven't
seen that that issue become uh a problem
with double spending.
Oh. Oh, no. And like uh could you like
little bit uh explain me the scenario of
like how transactions should not always
be instantaneous like around this? So,
so this this use case of me maybe if you
are a company and you're running payroll
on chain and um you know that um there
is a transaction that you're going to
make in the future um for a certain
amount to do payroll and it's on a
consistent cadence. You could actually
uh generate that transaction, sign it
and approve it offline and then
broadcast it on the day of the actual
transaction that needs to be sent out.
Oh, got it. Thank you. Yeah.
Okay.
Hey, how's it going?
Good. How you doing? I must have missed
the first part where you mentioned
multi-IG but um my question was just
revolving around like some of the
different use cases of multi-ig
combining that with you know humans
agents um you know for example in this
um contract evaluation you could have
like three different agents try to
evaluate the same contract and criteria
inside of multiig but what other what
other use cases of multi-IG and AI do
you see?
Great question. Um, you know, I I think
that um, you know, there could be a
world where um, you like you you have
multiple agents that may act as um, you
know, in in kind of like a a financial
uh, operations unit at a company, small
company, and you may have um, you know,
a CFO agent, a controller agent,
accountant agent, and those agents are
cross-checking each other's work and
things like that. But then ultimately
they need to do uh some sort of multi-
signature process to be able to sign off
on uh maybe transactions that are over
like $25,000.
Um so that that could be like a world
that we see uh with with agents and um
USDC.
Great. Thank you.
Yeah. Okay.
So where you using that AI? um for
reading the document and generating the
like what the contract should be. So
there is a human in the loop. Uh so for
in order to the in order for the human
to approve or reject it, he needs to go
through that document himself as well,
right? U so how exactly is that agent
saving any effort because the human has
to still go and read the document,
right?
Yeah. Yeah. So like you know right now
like this is just a a a simple
prototype, right? Um we could have gone
the extra mile and started out with
someone uh you know using NLP to like
just create like
a a simple prompt to say, "Hey, I want a
contract between, you know, me and this
other person that does these things."
And then the agent goes out and writes
it. and then the agent could actually,
you know, um parse out the information
that it wrote and then send a
notification to the two parties that
this is agreement for $100 and these are
the things that need to be met. Um so
that that's that's a world where we we
could have done that but like we were
just trying to put together a simple
prototype to just showcase the
combination of technology but this is
not you know something we we feel like
is you should you know deploy in
production and use right now but it's in
inspiration you know of combining these
different technologies.
Okay. Thanks.
Yes. Yeah.
So I guess um
yeah uh we don't have any other
questions. We can
close it out.
Thanks everyone.
[Music]